[Musique]
ce
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de v y pays il ya
aujourd'hui nous allons parler à
baseball et plus précisément d'un livre
de gaëtan alibert intitulé une histoire
populaire de baseball pour nous parle de
cet ouvrage nous recevons livi noah
gaëtan alibert sur ce plateau bonsoir
bonsoir et merci de l'invitation alors
de quoi parle ce livre ce livre parle de
baseball n'est pas que
c'est un livre qui va amener les
lectrices et lecteurs sur l'histoire du
baseball mais une histoire qui va être
connecté à la grande histoire du monde
alors particulièrement aux états unis
parce que c'est là où le baseball est né
et a pris une importance presque parfois
capita dans la culture populaire voire
même politique du pays mais on va aussi
aller dans d'autres contrées de ce monde
et donc ses services voilà qui est une
sorte d'odyssée à travers le temps et
l'espace oui bah moi j'essayerai de le
construire comme ça une sorte de à la
fois un essai de vulgarisation
historique autour du baseball mais aussi
une sorte de deux comptes ou de romans à
travers le portrait de cinq femmes et
cinq hommes qui ont eu une importance
particulière dans l'histoire du baseball
mais aussi dans la société dans lequel
ils ont évolué et évoluent est ce que
vous êtes vous même passionné de
baseball j'imagine que oui oui alors
c'est tardivement parce que je suis
arrivé dans le baseball à vers la fin de
ma vingtaine début trentaine quand je
suis arrivé sur paris en 2008 avant ça
je connaissais le baseball ce sens sans
plus j'avais découvert moi j'avais dans
mon petit bled des cévennes d'où je
viens du sud de la france un club savait
qu'il existait sans savoir vraiment ce
que ce que c'était c'est dans les années
2000 où j'ai découvert avec vous plaît
ah non le club du vigan les coyotes du
vigan et les clubs de montpellier dans
lequel j'ai vécu pendant dix ans je les
dépouilles mieux plus tard après deux
parties de montpellier bizarrement mais
on pourrait y revenir mais c'est
vraiment en arrivant c'est en gardant un
anime japonais qui s'appelle médor qui
m'a vraiment donné l'envi de connaître
ce sport et quand j'avais à paris je me
suis dis bah on travaille faut finir
nouvelle vie nouvelle ville pourquoi pas
un nouveau sport et c'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai rentré dans l'univers du
base-ball et je suis tombé
malheureusement très vite accro alors
vous avez écrit dans votre livre à ma
compagne gaby et ma fille charlotte dont
il faut louer la patience pour supporter
la dévorante passion du baseball j'ai un
vrai sens vous regardez beaucoup de
baseball à la télévision et que vous
avez sauvegardé
pas que regarder
c'est surtout que moi je n'aime pas être
acteur j'aime j'aime pas être spectateur
par dont j'aimais être acteur certes
quand je m'empare d'un sujet qui
m'intéresse qui nous passionne j'ai
besoin d'agir et quand je suis rentré
dans le baseball je pourrais pas être
simplement un consommateur de sport
comme malheureusement on le trouve dans
beaucoup de clubs et pas que dans le
baseball mais j'avais besoin de
m'investir donc sud une bénévole j'ai
coaché j'ai arbitré j'ai pris des
responsabilités dans club à la
communication à la direction
à l'époque c'était au par invest et club
et est en fait je concerne le documenter
sur le baseball son histoire et moi je
suis un féru d'histoire j'adore ce qui
est lié à la culture aux arts est en
fait le baseball à une culture
historique
extrêmement riche à des connexions avec
la culture les arts extrêmement
foisonnante et du coup j'ai eu envie de
toujours plus à prendre et quand
j'apprends j'aime bien partager ce
savoir la et du coup j'ai commencé à
écrire sur des sites sur l'histoire du
baseball sa culture et puis plus
récemment à participer à des à des
podcasts du coup c'est assez prenant en
terme de temps à décrire de préparer des
podcasts de les tourner puis ensuite
d'écrire un livre parce que c'est
beaucoup de temps et d'énergie en plus
d'être bénévole et en plus effectivement
de regarder des matchs alors les matchs
américain c'est surtout à la sur
internet ou à la télé mais ça du temps
tard dans la nuit heureusement depuis
peu je travaille de nuit donc ça me
permet de regarder un peu plus
facilement des des matches mais oui
c'est ça prend du temps une passion
prend du temps de toute manière ils vont
regarder principalement le championnat
américain où vous intéressez un petit
peu à tous les championnats dans le
monde entier je fuis deux championnats
premièrement la major league baseball
aux états unis parce que bah c'est la
grande scène du baseball mondiale et que
moi j'écris je fais des podcasts là
dessus donc je suis ça notamment les new
york santis qui monte de tuer mon équipe
préférée et puis également le
championnat français toujours un oeil
sur ce qui se passe notamment les
grosses équipes comme les cougars de
montigny mais aussi rouen le puck sénart
on va dire qu'en ile de france au tour
de france n'a pas mal de très gros clubs
très performant et puis de temps en
temps un oeil sur aussi les équipes au
japon ou dans nos lacs latine qui sont
les deux autres grands pôles du baseball
dans le monde consacrés combien de temps
par semaine au baseball
je pourrais pas vraiment donné en termes
de temps passé déjà c'est un peu
variable selon les saisons la la saison
l'a aimée b reprend donc ça va me
prendre un peu plus de temps pour chaque
chaque semaine c'est très variable mais
on va dire que c'est une passion qui
structurent montant quel est l'objectif
de ce livre c'est transmettre votre
passion justement oui l'idée du livre
c'était transmettre ma passion à deux
types de public les passionnés et les
néophytes j'ai écrit ce livre vraiment
pour pouvoir intéresser ces deux publics
là parce que bon c'est un sujet de niche
si on parle que de baseball et je ne
trouvais pas forcément ça intéressant de
ne parler qu'à des gens qui s'y
connaissent déjà ou qui qui connaissent
déjà l'idée c'était aussi de sortir du
cercle des passionnés pour aller dire
aux gens ben oui le baseball asic et
contrairement aux images reçues aux
idées reçues qu'on peut avoir de lui un
sport l'ene lieu très lointain avec les
américains qui peuvent comprendre temps
de montrer que c'est un sport qui est
universel déjà c'est une des pratiques
sportives les plus mondialisées qui soit
et puis c'est c'est un sport qui va au
delà justement de la simple sphère
sportive qui a des connexions avec
l'histoire avec la culture qui parle des
nations dans lequel il a il a notamment
aidé notamment devenu un sport référence
un sport majeur et donc voilà l'idée
c'était de construire un récit qui
permettent de contenter les passionnés
qui en france parfois on peu de mal à
trouver une lecture en français sur le
base-ball et de aussi permettre à des
gens qui n'y connaissent rien de se
rendre compte que le baseball est
extrêmement intéressant même si parfois
on a pu s'ennuyer devant un match ce que
je peux concevoir c'est pas toujours
très simples sont les matches qu'on
regarde et dire qu'en fait c'est un
sport qui est extrêmement passionnant et
comment vous pour parler justement un
public amateur
l'idée c'est de trouver la bonne astuce
mois l'astuce elle a été je pense de
d'aller chercher des parcours hors norme
si je si on est partis de si je suis
parti sur des parcours hors norme et pas
forcément sur des
détenus diorite et qu'on connaît même en
france gère bruce joe dimaggio de jackie
robinson ça c'est parfois des noms qui
peuvent parler à certaines personnes en
france parce que ça a traversé
l'atlantique dont je suis allé chercher
des personnes qui sont assez méconnu
même aux états unis parfois qui sont pas
forcément les personnalités les plus
connues du monde du baseball il est
connu des parcours assez incroyable
comme edith hughton qui est dans le
premier chapitre qui était une joueuse
de baseball dans les années 20 qui est
parti avec son équipe féminine faire une
tournée au japon qui se retrouvent
abandonnés avec son équipe au japon sans
le sou par les promoteurs parce que là
elle a tourné à hamel a mal débuté par
apporter assez d'argent et donc elles
sont retrouvés en galère en plein milieu
d'un pays étranger ne connaissait pas la
langue connaissait pas la culture elles
ont été sauvées par des bienfaiteurs qui
leur ont permis de revenir aux états
unis fin voilà et en même temps c'est
insolite et en même temps ça dit aussi
beaucoup de la condition des femmes dans
le baseball et dans la société à ce
moment là donc il essaie d'articuler ça
des parcours assez insolite pour
vraiment intéressé accrocher ce côté
comptent un peu romanesque mais aussi
parler de l'histoire d'une manière plus
générale etc dot c'est ça l'objectif
c'est ça c'est pour ça aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de notes de bas de page dans sa
douche parce que vous avez parfois du
mal à laisser certaines informations sur
le côté mais il ya beaucoup enfin ça
dépend les chapines il sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de digressions serge j'aime
bien partir d'un parcours originel mais
aussi d'aller voir les rencontres qui
ont été faits lors de ce parcours et qui
permettent de s'ouvrir sur d'autres
histoires et je pense que ça fait 1
réussi qui est assez foisonnant il ya
près de 400 pages mais qui est
apparemment de retour que j'ai eus qu
est extrêmement intéressant parce que ça
se dit assez simplement malgré le
foisonnement d'informations vous
utilisez beaucoup de termes techniques
en anglais dans votre livre c'est un
choix oui c'est un choix parce que je
souhaitais immerger le lecteurs et
lectrices dans le récit est dans la
culture populaire du du baseball en fait
je mixe des fois je vais partir sur des
termes anglais des fois je vais partir
sur des termes français gilles explique
tous les termes techniques sont
expliqués dans le livre en note de bas
de page pour que quand la fin quand on a
un terme qui apparaît et qu'on ne
comprend pas on peut de suite savoir
quelle est la référence plutôt que
d'aller sur un glossaire lexique enfin 2
en fin de boucle donc vraiment l'idée
c'était d'avoir une lecture très fluide
mais quand même de mettre des
effectivement des éléments un peu plus
techniques ou des termes anglais qui ne
sont pas forcément compris de prime
abord pour justement que la personne
peut s'immerger dans l'univers du
base-ball et puissent ensuite il
naviguer tranquillement dans votre livre
vous parlez également beaucoup de femmes
dans le baseball dans le softball il ya
notamment eu ni viennoise on vous
parlait sur sur quelques pages c'est
mélissa mahieu qui a grandi ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux aux cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux est ce qu'elle
représente l'évolution du baseball
peut-être
beaucoup parler d'elle oui alors il a
fait beaucoup parler d'elle notamment de
m ce qu'a été la première femme à
l'international à pouvoir être signé par
une franchise delà de la mlb ça fait un
buzz mondial on a parlé beaucoup aux
états unis notamment sont des grandes
chaînes sportives américaines au japon
enfin un petit peu partout et encore
aujourd'hui quand je passe sur un mètre
des points comme ils font un article sur
où on est le baseball au féminin belle
mélissa régulièrement et effectivement
est mentionné moi je voulais parler
2010la dans le livre absolument tout
comme je voulais absolument qu'une
parité dans les personnalités donc c'est
effectivement ces cinq femmes cinq
hommes c'est une parité qui était voulu
ce que je voulais que le matrimoine du
baseball soit mise en avant c'est une
histoire qui a longtemps été enfouis lui
dans l'ombre qui ressort depuis quelques
décennies petit à petit mes parents
c'était parfois là où j'ai dû faire les
recherches les plus poussées pour avoir
des informations contrairement aux
hommes du livre et je voulais
effectivement parler de mélissa alors
j'ai pris un autre personnalité pour
être le fil rouge qui est julie croteau
masse que elle permet de montrer comment
le baseball féminin a pu avoir une
renaissance à la fin des années 80 mais
c'était voilà ça me permettait aussi de
parler de messac a eu un impact
extrêmement fort en france elle a été un
déclencheur d'un mouvement beaucoup plus
profond pour permettre aux femmes
d'accéder au baseball parce que jusqu'à
au milieu des années 2010 une femme à
partir de 16 ans elle devait soit arrêté
le baseball est passé au softball soir
et et au cours
donc là maintenant les femmes peuvent
jouer au softball et au baseball en
france y compris en seniors et ça amélie
ça a beaucoup aidé à cette cause et puis
surtout elle est le symbole d'un
baseball au féminin qui a retrouvé des
couleurs ces dernières décennies alors
si même si maintenant elle joue au
softball aux états unis d'un
louisiana university qui est une des
plus grandes équipes universitaires de
softball aux états unis elle garde
toujours ce lien avec le baseball rdr
était championne d'europe en 2010 neuf
avec l'équipe de france
c'était vraiment important de parler de
mélissa c'est une personnalité à part
dans notre culture française du baseball
s'ils ont très rapidement comment vous
voyez l'évolution du baseball ici en
france
rapidement il nous reste une trentaine
de secondes a plutôt positivement
pendant très longtemps il a été dans
l'ombre depuis une grosse dizaine
d'années il le se médiatise et j'espère
que mon livre va contribuer à le faire
sortir encore plus de l'ombre merci à
vous à gaëtan alibert merci d'avoir
participé à ce nouveau numéro de v y
paie vous nous avez donné envie de nous
mettre baseball je rappelle le titre de
votre livre une histoire populaire du
baseball aux éditions à blake les funt
[Musique]